author Corey doctors politics are just
heterodox enough to provide moments of
delightful confirmation bias and squirm
inducing challenge for readers of nearly
every ideological strike I spent my
whole life in the political left of
varying stripes including barracks
during political life I think I've heard
people earnestly say politically correct
it twice doctor Oh a civil libertarian
who identifies with the political left
has staked out a broad and eccentric
beat for himself covering topics from
drones to digital rights management to
open source software creation I spoke
with dr. Oh about his latest novel walk
away we began with a question about what
happens when information becomes
contraband
do you think that sort of the underlying
conditions of free speech as it is
associated with dubious technologies are
they getting better or worse
there is a pure free speech argument and
there's a scientific argument that just
says you know it's not scientific not
published you have to let people who
disagree with you and who dislike you
read your work and find the dumb
mistakes you've made and call you an
idiot for having made them otherwise you
just end up kidding yourself and then
you know your h-bomb blows up in your
face right and and atomic knowledge was
the first category of knowledge that
scientists weren't allowed to freely
talk about as opposed to like trade
secrets but like scientific knowledge
that knowing it was a crime and so it's
a kind of original sin of science but
there's a difference between an atomic
secret and the framework for keeping
that a secret and a secret about a
vulnerability in a computer system and
and they're often lumped together so I
was at a I was on a holiday family
holiday we were at like a scuba resort
in the Caribbean in a little island
called Roatan in Honduras and there was
this family of dc-area
spooks like multi-generational and
Grandpa what had been like with you
Sayed when the tanks rolled on Hungary
been in Budapest and like all of the
kids worked for undisclosed three-letter
agencies and so we're like sitting in it
in the pool one day and talking about
cyber weapons and sadhya
like you did on vacation that's what I
do I'm I that's my idea of a good time
so the guy said like well what about
cyber weapons like can't why shouldn't
we develop cyber weapons why shouldn't
we a cyber war and I said there's a
difference between a secret bomb and a
secret vulnerability in a computer
operating system because if I invent the
h-bomb it may be unwise like keeping the
physics of the h-bomb a secret do not
does not make Americans more vulnerable
to atomic attack than disclosing it
maybe it would help them at the margins
build slightly better bomb shelters but
it's really it's it's not the same thing
as me discovering a vulnerability in
Windows and saying it would be great if
I could attack former Soviet bloc
countries or countries in Middle East or
jihad ease or drug runners by keeping
this vulnerability of secret and
assuming that nobody else discovers that
vulnerability and uses it to attack the
people I'm charged to protect that miss
state is called into question the whole
scientific enterprise because we really
only know one way to make computers
secure and that to publish what we think
we know about why they're secure now and
see what dumb mistakes our enemies and
friends can locate and help us remediate
and so you end up in this place where
these vulnerabilities that you are
blithely assuming will be independently
rediscovered by your average adversaries
and exploited against you and yours end
up getting exploited against you and
yours and not just by state actors but
by petty criminals too and this is one
thing we're learning after the vault
seven leaks is that a lot of those
vulnerabilities were independently
rediscovered and weaponized not just by
governments and by military contractors
who serve them but by like you know
dum-dums who have crappy little identity
theft rackets right you know I guess
maybe in in the reason verse it's a
function of an imperfect market that the
person who discovers the vulnerability
that could be used by someone who could
make millions with it ends up migrating
to a dumb-dumb who makes hundreds with
it and if we had better market for these
vulnerabilities maybe we'd have a more
efficient market place and maybe it
would only be exploited by people
seeking high-value targets instead of
targets of opportunity where you're just
looking for you know scanning all of
ipv4 for people who've got CCTVs or
maybe the highest bidder would typically
be the person who actually wanted to
close that vulnerability at least in
some cases well except that would be a
state right and like the states so far
are bidding on these loans just to
exploit them like that would be great
and and this comes to this is the crux
of the argument right is that keeping
security vulnerable
these a secret is itself a recipe for
being exploited it means that the only
people like a lot of contraband
dysfunctions the only people who end up
knowing that secret are people who are
weaponizing it and not the people
against whom it's being exploited until
it becomes so widespread in its exploit
that it can no longer be denied so Mirai
the internet of things were now is very
widely known because it was very widely
exploited before that it was a cozy
secret among dum-dums and creeps who
used it for denial of service and
blackmail so this is particularly
salient because we only know how to make
one kind of computer and that's the
general-purpose computer that can run
all the programs and we have computers
that are now at the center of all of our
policy problems because computers at the
center of all of our life every element
of our life so in theory we could maybe
solve all of our automotive problems by
changing which programs the computers
and the cars can run don't let it run
the program that runs over children
right right and in theory we can fix
maybe some of our aviation security
problems and we can pick some of our
child pornography problems and like all
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse the
mafia child porn terrorism and organ
always forget the fourth mafia child
porn terrorism and uh not money
laundering goodness me I don't know man
and and and famine just throw us all for
yeah old school or sin right right on
YouTube buffering I'm sure probably know
that's one of the ten plagues of
Passover I think yeah I know it is it's
right after the life and before the
death that's right yeah so this belief
that we can solve our problems by making
computers that are like correspond to a
theory object that doesn't exist
anywhere in theory which is the computer
that runs all the programs except for
the one you don't like involves
necessarily prohibition on disclosing
defects in the design of that computer
that might let you run the forbidden
program and that means that security
vulnerabilities faster in those devices
and we have a perfect storm of
terribleness
in which the consolation and devices
is that we are designing to control what
kinds of programs we can run is
monotonically expanding and the ways in
which those devices can harm us is also
monotonically extending and our ability
to report security defects in those and
continuously improve them is contracting
and this is catastrophic right and so
like I think that we can leave aside the
philosophical argument about whether we
should or shouldn't have free speech or
what its limits are and we can go to a
purely utilitarian argument that just
says if you don't want bad firmware
loads being over-the-air updated into
your pacemaker your car the CCTV in your
bedroom and the toaster that could burn
down your house you know we need to have
a robust culture of Investigation and
discovery and disclosure of security
defects in those products and that is
just not compatible with cyber war
digital rights management crypto
backdoors anything else that requires
controls on which programs computers can
run
it's almost sounds like something that's
analogous to the problems with
monocropping right like there's there's
a sort of one type of computer it's
everywhere and we have now elaborate
pesticides and we have elaborate over
size and we have controls over who can
plant what when and who has the
intellectual property on which seeds but
sort of on some fundamental level the
problem is just it's all the same kind
of thing and therefore vulnerable to a
single apocalyptic event is that fair or
is that the overworking the analogy I
think it is a little because although we
don't know for sure what other computer
architectures might exist the only one
that we've really been able to scale up
and make good is this sort of
turing-complete von Neumann machine and
there are some smart people at the Media
Lab where where I have an unemployment
who think that maybe we could do other
things but like say you know corn where
we have already about yeah indigenous
right like raising instances more like
really it's just the one computer and we
yeah well it's kind of like maybe we
just have one physics and if only we had
lots of different physics then nuclear
bombs wouldn't always work right
and so if turing completeness is like
latent in the fabric of the universe
which seems to be this weird thing where
like we try to design toy computing
environments that just do a few things
and they inevitably turn out to be
bootstrap Abul into the full suite of
turing completeness you know like maybe
that maybe it is there right like Magic
the Gathering is Turing complete right
and and like you really know how to
speak to our viewers that's right that's
right my Jack he's in a long time
but it is fear but you learn Photoshop
that's probably just true because we're
actually all living in a simulation that
was created to be that that's the
condition they're testing here right I
am of the stripe of science fiction
writer that thinks that all of those
things are useful metaphors and
dangerous assumptions about reality
what's the danger in making that
assumption about reality I mean I don't
actually have a strong view one way or
the other on this question but I am
intrigued by your use of the word danger
there so it seems so first of all the
arguments seem to me to have that the
reek of like collegiate mind game logic
games right like I had a roommate and a
dear friend actually one of the people
walk away is dedicated to Eric Stewart
who died unexpectedly a few years ago
without any proximate cause just didn't
wake up one morning but he was very
clever and in high school one day he sat
down he said so the universe is
infinitely prolonged right it goes on
forever and I'm like what am i
understanding he said we have finite
life spans yeah said anything finite
divided by something infinite is zero
it's like all right he said therefore
the probability of us being alive at
this moment is zero like okay and the
only thing that is nonzero and divided
by infinity is infinity and like it's
like therefore we have infinitely
prolonged lives and we are immortal like
can argue with your reasoning but I
don't think it's true is it not fair to
say though that you're maybe you're not
your target demographic but your de
facto demographic is in fact like dudes
who would like to have their mind blow
owned by late-night conversations in
dorms is that an unfair call for now go
to your Ganesha Alfred no no no I'm all
for having a conversation but I think
that it's the difference between having
a thought experiment and a religious
faith right and odd experiments are cool
and interesting and like I think science
fiction has this great signature move
which is that it reaches into the world
and it plucks a single technology out
that is part of this complex matrix of
technologies that are affecting our
lives and it imagines a world in a
bottle where that one technology is the
central fact and where everything else
if it's present is just garnish around
the edges and by magnifying it in this
comic way right this is caricature way
it surfaces some of the latent emotional
and you know moral questions around the
technology that are otherwise kind of
hard to tease out from the from the from
that big matrix it's like when the
doctor goes and swabs your throat and
then you know rubs it on a petri dish
and Lisa for the weekend what she looks
at on Monday is not an accurate model of
your body
it's a usefully inaccurate model of your
body in which one thing is blown up as a
diagnostic tool to let us understand it
you know it's the physicist imagining
the perfectly spherical cow on a
frictionless surface and uniform density
right not because we have perfectly
spherical cows or frictionless surfaces
or uniform density but that's a good
first approximation for testing all your
ideas again and assuming that the cow is
a sphere is a useful and positive thing
to do when you're writing science
fiction and maybe slightly less oh and
yeah basically this actually weird
reality right I think in a lot of ways
this new book is I don't know is it a
prequel is it related in some way to
down on the Magic Kingdom it seems like
a similar universe has a sort of
political takeaway that you would want
people to get out of those two different
books has that shifted between them at
all either because your views have
changed or because kinds of facts on the
ground have changed so I think that
science fiction is not predictive in any
meaningful way and I think that it's
certainly not great at it
yes I mean I always say we're Texas
marksmen we fire the shotgun into
to the barn and draw the target around
the place for the pellet head just
ignore all those science fiction stories
that never came true and yes but I also
think that like prediction is way
overrated I like what Dante did to the
fortune tellers you know he put them in
a pit of molten [ __ ] up to their nipples
with their heads twisted around
backwards weeping into their own ass
cracks for having pretended that the
future was knowable right if the future
is knowable then it's inevitable and if
it's inevitable why are we even
bothering right why get out of bed if
the future is going to happen no matter
what we do except I guess you're for
ordained to write so I'm not a fatalist
right the reason I'm an activist is
because I think that the future at least
in part is up for grabs I think that
there are great forces that produce some
outcomes that are deterministic or semi
deterministic and I think that there are
other elements that are up for grabs and
I think that the forces are the result
of the elements that are up for grabs
that's you know the parts that we
intervene in become unstoppable forces
later that then we can damp through
other mechanisms and other interventions
and so I think what science fiction does
is not predictive but sometimes
diagnostic because across all the
science fiction that has been written
and is being written and all the stuff
that's being greenlit by editors or has
been greenlit by editors and all the
stuff that readers can find and raise up
or ignore there's a kind of natural
selection at work where the stuff that
like resonates with our aspirations and
fears about technology and our futures
that stuff gets buoyed up by market
forces by the marketplace of ideas and
becomes a really excellent tool for
knowing what's in the minds of the world
so the book itself considered on its own
is a good way to know what's in the mind
of the writer the books would succeed
tell you what's in the mind of the world
and and if there's a lot of this stuff
kind of coming to - to a prominence at
this moment I think it does say
something about the moment that we live
in that there's a certain amount of
pessimism there's a fear that we are
being stampeded to war
a mutually distrustful internally
divided future where we end up attacking
each other rather than pulling together
I think even the most cynical person
understands that if civilization
collapses and you run for the hills
that you aren't going to be a part of
rebuilding it right that the people who
are the part of rebuilding are the
people who run to the middle and kind of
get the powerplant working again reopen
the hospital and get their water
filtration plant working again and so
that mood of distrust and anger of
zero-sum nests all though I just read an
article this morning about how zero-sum
doesn't mean there are some and that von
Neumann has this who clean a term had
this very specialized definition that we
all use wrong but I couldn't figure out
what it was supposed to mean because it
was 5:00 in the morning and I'd only got
inside our sleep but but this notion
that like my gain is you're lost and
that there's not enough to go around and
this big game of musical chairs and the
chairs are being removed at speed is a
is a theme in a lot of the science
fiction that's prominent right now so
walk away is in some ways a prequel to
down and out of the Magic Kingdom I
certainly reread down on the Magic
Kingdom with a pen and a highlighter and
some post-its and made tons of notes
before I started work on walk away and I
have a whole file of themes that I
wanted to pick up some of that is
understanding that I've come to and you
know the 15 plus years since I wrote it
and some of it is wanting to respond
back to the people who read down-and-out
in the Magic Kingdom as a utopia and who
didn't who didn't understand that that
there were dystopic elements it was a
very mixed future and that reputation
economics have the same winner-take-all
problem that that tiket Ian rate of
growth is always less than the rate of
return on on capital problem that
produces you know insane runaway wealth
disparity and dysfunction with like miss
allocation of resources
literally because in American in down
another Magic Kingdom your ability to
like run Disney World is based on how
much esteem people hold you in and so
literally you can walk in and start
handing out tickets and if the people
treat your tickets as though they're the
right tickets then you get to be the
Czar of Disneyworld
right which is the premise of the book
and so you get these crazy resource
misallocations get all these other
problems and that it's papered over with
meritocracy which I'm sure you know was
cleaned as a satirical term to describe
the delusion that the reason that you
have so much and everyone else has so
little is because you're better than
them right and and yet I'm sure you get
all the time people coming up and saying
to you oh my god you basically predicted
ubers reputation also and you know
certainly while you weren't alone in
thinking about those reputation
mechanisms and as you mentioned Charlie
stress has a bunch of great stuff in his
books about about how that might look
well and I stole a few flash stock karma
so it feels it feels both normal and
dystopian to people simultaneously well
but I think Boober is normal and
dystopian for a lot of people to like I
think all the dysfunctions of uber
reputation economics where there's it's
one-sided I can tank your business by
giving you an unfair review where you
have this kind of weird like mannered
kabuki in some ubers where people are
like super obsequious to try and get you
to 5-star them and all of that other
stuff that is like I think that's
actually characteristics done on the
Magic Kingdom I think I probably did
predict Hoover pretty well with them and
what would happen if there are these
reputation economies which is that you
would quickly have a half and a half not
and you would and the halves would be
able to in a very one-sided way allocate
reputation to have-nots or take it away
from them that without redress with that
rule of law without the ability to do
any of the things we want currency to do
so it's like it's not a store value it's
not a unit of exchange it's not a
measure of account
it's instead this like it's just it's a
pure system for allowing the powerful to
exercise power over the power
and yet isn't the sort of positive spin
on that well yeah but the way we used to
do that allocation was just by punching
each other in the face uh well that's
one of the ways we used to I was really
informed by a book by David Graeber
called death the first 5000 years where
he points out that like the
anthropological story that we all just
used to punch each other in the face all
the time doesn't really match evidence
that there's certainly some places where
they punch each other in the face it
there's other places where they just
kind of got along including lots of
places where they got along like through
having long arguments or through like
guilting each other or by you know doing
lots of other things that we're like
functional I'm feeling like the five
stars on the uber thing is better than
the long arguments or the guilt but
maybe that's well that's because you
don't have to drive uber for a living
and you've never had to worried that
tomorrow you wouldn't be able to that's
certainly true yeah talk to me a little
bit about the universe that that walk
away exists in and in particular I'm
interested in it's sort of quasi
anarchic properties and the way that
that sort of what exists of the law and
then the people who are operating
outside of it how that interaction works
so the mainstream walk away world what's
called default which is a term I stole
from from Burning Man that the default
world is one in which the rule of law is
entirely tilted to the favor of a small
cadre of super wealthy people who have
kind of gained rigged the system and
everybody else the 99% either is in this
very precarious position where some of
them are needed to make the automated
systems go and some of them are needed
to make sure that the people who do the
work don't don't get too uppity because
they can always be fired and then
everyone else is kind of surplus to
requirements and a lot of them walk away
a lot of them because they can escape
hatch into a kind of bohemian demi-monde
where they move into brownfield sites
left behind by toxic post-industrial
implosion they use drones to find the
leftovers of the civilization that had
one
in there and then they use software from
the UN High Commission on refugees to
figure out how to recombine that to
build a kind of fully automated luxury
communist
civilization where they just you know
you go on a scavenger hunt you find all
the stuff and you build a huge dr. Seuss
e'en amazing luxury hotel that anyone
can stay in and that anyone can be the
Tsar of and that anyone can can kind of
contribute to and it's built sort of
like a wiki where people add things and
people remove things and you can see who
added what and who removed what and you
can decide kind of collectively through
deliberation and sometimes through you
know shitty arguments and sometimes
through very reasonable arguments and
one of the things that a lot of the walk
away culture aspires to is is that kind
of rationalist mode of argument where
we're talking things over rigorously
front iron man each other's arguments is
the best way to kind of win one over and
decide what the best thing to do is and
not just how to win and it's pretty
stable because it turns out the default
doesn't mind having an escape hatch and
you know Bohemia is are cute right I
mean there's a reason that like loads of
fast fashion places and there are
designers to Burning Man to make notes
on what to knock off for the runway next
year because Bohemia Zara cool thing to
mine it's you know grunge went from like
you know
Seattle's underground seedy underground
to like Sears in in six months right and
so Bohemia is are cute they're living
labs but then a group of scientists
who've been working in default figuring
out the secrets of practical immortality
for the super-rich decide that they
don't really want to be complicit in
helping the human race speciate entities
like infinitely prolonged god-like
humans and you know the rest of us who
are just mayflies receding in their
rearview mirror so they engage in a kind
of Promethean act they steal the secrets
of immortality which they after all
discovered bring them to the rest of us
and then the super-rich realize that
they're going to have to spend the rest
of eternity with people they think of as
being unworthy and that triggers the
Hellfire missiles in all-out war this is
an analogy to open-source software
development and probably the phrase
open-source is one
that people use incredibly widely
without really understanding what it
means I mean people use it to just mean
vaguely collaborative or you know it
sort of has words often use it to mean
just stuff in the newspaper open sources
it has it has a whole separate meeting
which is stuff people generally know
mmm-hmm how much of your inspiration was
directly from I know you're a part of
that community or you're sort of you're
sort of stuck in there quite deep and
how much of it is again just kind of a
metaphor and let's not work too hard to
make the parallel so I actually I'm
working out whatever the thing that
underpin screen open source software is
which i think is like Koshien
coordination so I think that like
abundance is this triangle and up here
is what we want right so kings you know
wrote that paper in nineteen thirty our
grandchildren will struggle to fill
their three-day work weeks because they
will be able to produce all the things
that humanity could reasonably want and
he grossly underestimated the elasticity
of our demand and now you have people
like Mary Kondo making a cottage
industry that is like convincing us that
really all we want is like a single
smooth river rock that reminds us of our
mother is jus like they give you yeah
makes us feel joy and so like how much
you want is obviously elastic and it can
go up and it can go down right and so
that's one of the parameters on
abundance that we have to think about
and then over here is like how much we
can make right so 3d printing automation
all that stuff and and both of those
have seen significant changes in the
last couple of decades marketing a be
splitting you know new additive
manufacturing tools automated milling
robotics all of those have been profound
changes in our world but all of the real
action is over in this other corner
which is in logistics and then that's
like getting the stuff that people want
to the people who want it after you've
made it and figuring out how to remake
it and figuring out what happens to it
when we're done with it so bruce
sterling growth is very influential on
me essay in the mid 2000s called shaping
things published by MIT press where he
posits an object called a spine
and a spine is a is a is a good object
that is immaterial it exists as
information until someone needs it and
then it's manufactured but it's
manufactured and designed in a way to
gracefully decompose back into the
material stream when its duty cycle is
over and it's manufactured in a way so
that it's use generates data about its
efficacy in ways that it can be improved
so that every time it's made anew it's
better and spines are a really
provocative answer to the question of
like how we can realize the Promethean
project of both the the heterodox right
and heterodox left you know that the
letting every peasant live like a lord
as opposed to insisting either on the
left that every that every lord should
be made to live like a peasant or on the
right that lords and peasants are an
inevitable fact of the world and
there'll always be lords and always
because it's maybe we incentivize people
by having that difference the way that
we get every peasant to live like a lord
in a planet that only has one planets
worth of material is that we find better
ways to connect the material that people
need with the people who have it and
where it is at any given moment so that
rather than like everybody having to own
a car we have cars that are services but
we also have completely negotiable
moment-to-moment things that you might
need a car for and so when there aren't
cars available the things that you can
do instead of being in a car are sort of
brought to the fore so like Google runs
this data center in Belgium in a place
where two thirds of the time it's so
cool that they don't need the air
conditioning the other third of the time
they just turn it off and their file
system is so good at migrating data away
from places that are shutting down and
into places where it's running that it
doesn't really matter you know a lot of
places that do aluminum smelting because
it's so energy intensive they use
aluminum smelting as a kind of battery
they say well we need to smelt so many
tons of aluminum this year and when we
have lots of solar or lots of wind there
are lots of tidal power we don't have
anything to use it for so we
melt the the aluminum men and not at the
moment when other people are trying to
turn on their lights to run their air
conditioning or run their Google data
centers that kind of coordination where
like at the moment that something is
needed it's and at the moment where it's
cheap to do it it's done is
characteristic of like efficient market
hypothesis its characteristic planned
economy theory it's the thing that
everyone is kind of shooting for and
it's the thing that free and open-source
software has given us is the ability to
coordinate ourselves very efficiently
without having to put up with a lot of
hierarchy to late bind why we're doing
things or whether we're all on the same
side to be able to take things that
we've done together where we've reached
a breaking point and split them in two
and have each of us pursue it in our own
direction without having to pay too high
a cost or even have a lot of acrimony
that's like that's the free software
world I'm trying to imagine like what
would it mean be like to build
skyscrapers the way we make
encyclopedias in the 21st century so
you're over there imagining this world
but the place where the kind of social
and political panic or preoccupation is
happening is really it's in that other
corner of your triangle it's in the
logistics corner where were where the
robots are going to come and take away
our that's the manufacturing right sorry
that may be a job where you wearing
where we're sort of currently culturally
perseverating is is over there sure um
you know I think this idea that it turns
out people don't want leisure
on some kind of deep level is the thing
that I'm particularly hearing on the
right right the Conservatives are are
sort of doubling down on you know oh
actually there's there's value in work
there's value in difference there's
value in as you say maybe those
differences incentivize people and
there's a sort of conservative version
of the panic about the robots are taking
our jobs then there's a liberal version
of the panic about the robots are taking
our jobs which is what's going to happen
to the truck drivers right Ram when all
those are automated but why is that the
thing we're panicking about now well
because I think that we tend to worry a
lot about the first-order effects and
the second and third order effects tend
to come a little too late
Gardner Dozois very famously said that
the job of a science fiction writer
shouldn't be to just think of the car in
the movie theater and invent the
drive-in but also infer the sexual
revolution but you know I I say to
Gardner
once you've inferred the sexual
revolution maybe you could spare a
moment to think that the sexual
revolution happening in cars meant that
for the first time people had a reason
to carry government-issued ID which was
to get laid right and that like the
Shibboleth of papers please which
historically has been like a marker of
totalitarian you know descent into
totalitarian misery net became an
everyday thing and that today a lot of
the data base nation is the progeny of
that strange moment where technology and
social mores came together thanks to
movie theaters and cars in the sexual
revolution and give us all driver's
licenses right and so I think that
science fiction writers do like to think
past the first-order effect of what
would it mean if there weren't a lot of
truck driving jobs I mean is it fair to
say that science fiction writers are
doing the same thing as a good economist
or a good political economist in
thinking about unintended consequences
it's not just unintended consequence
because I think making all truck drivers
into you know desperate xenophobic
populist to vote for you know who vote
for strong man leaders was not the
intended consequence of the self-driving
car project right and yet that's the
fear of that that's that's well that's
what our pollute there's a fear that
that's what our political moment
reflects I think that it's more like the
job of a science fiction writer is to
not even necessarily to map the
territory but to point out that there's
territory to be mapped right there is a
game we play when we argue about policy
or tell stories and the game is what's
in the frame so this is famous science
fiction story called the cold equation I
don't know if you know it's taught in
engineering schools all the time and
it's it's about a spaceship pilot who's
piloting a small craft full of vaccine
to a planet where there is a potential
world killing plague and if he doesn't
get the vaccine there
everybody on the planet will die and
there is a young girl who stowed away on
his ship and when he discovers her he is
aghast because he knows that the ship
doesn't have any extra fuel it has no
autopilot it can only land if he pilots
it if there's any access way to look
crash and without all of that everyone
on that planet will die and that's why
he has to shut that girl at the airlock
and they spend 15 pages trying to figure
out why they don't have to shove her out
the airlock in many shoves are at the
airlock it sounds like a sexier version
of the charlie problem right it is it's
it's just another sexy version of the
trolley problem and what's out of the
frame here is that the author is like
the author set up the rules of this
thought experiment and the author
decided that auto pilots weren't a thing
that reserve fuel wasn't a thing that's
sending colonists with a supply of
vaccine wasn't a thing right all of
those all that stuff is out of frame so
I think that science fiction is about
pointing out in some ways that there are
things that are out of the frame that
don't properly belong out of the frame
who's who's ruling out is arbitrary
rather than or customary which another
way of saying the same thing I when I
saw the title of the book before I
hadn't even seen the illustration on the
cover anything I immediately thought of
the the ones who walk away from Oh me
less sure yeah and wondered if that was
getting it the sort of this incredibly
poetic kind of versatile glowing
scenario about you know when do you have
to sort of fully disengage from society
because it's based on an immoral premise
I wondered if that would be what this
book was going to be doing and I think
in a little bit of a way it is and I
think the tension is there at all yeah I
think the connection is that so the book
was originally called utopia okay
and it's thesis is that a utopian
society as we started saying as one that
fails gracefully no necessarily one that
works well and I sent it to Kim Stanley
Robinson for a quote and Stan Reddit and
gave me a wonderful quote and then said
and by the way I don't understand why
this book isn't called walk away and I
was like you're totally right and I
asked my editor or my agent they were
like Stan is totally right and so we
changed the title to walk away but Stan
might have been thinking of of lagoon
story
last question when you go to jail what
is it going to be for ah
what will the charge be or why will they
live a I like that you ask that
distinction and you may answer either
way uh so you know I have lots of
different kinds of privilege that I
think has kept me in reasonably out of
harm's way not just being like a white
middle-class articulate dude with half a
million Twitter followers but also like
working at a civil liberties law firm
filled with lawyers whose numbers I
write on my arm before I cross borders
you know ah your answer can just be I'm
invincible man Yeah right about a lot
because I'm a I'm a dirty foreigner I'm
a Canadian on a green card and as we
heard in the Supreme Court this week it
is virtually impossible to not have some
way in which you are technically
violating immigration rules when you are
on a green card crossing borders
whatever just look you know as the
justices at the Supreme Court ask like
if it says list all your known aliases
until I forget a childhood nickname does
that mean that I've I can be deported or
jailed for for immigration fraud and the
state's position was yes that is at any
regardless of whether or not the
omission is material the act of omission
itself violates the statute and
qualifies you and given the highly
arbitrary nature of borders and the very
deep end Timothy towards the people who
cross them from many of the people whose
job it is to inspect those people who
cross them that's the place where I have
the most worry I really do worry a lot
about that because I cross the border
all the time and I worry that like I I
don't know what I would do if I were
required to decrypt my devices I have a
certain amount of like purging I do
before I cross borders to not so to be
able to decrypt my devices if I if I'm
made to but then you know there's this
whole on unknown area which is like what
about making you log into your cloud
services and if you don't have the
password what about calling the people
who have the past
saying mr. doctoral doesn't get at an
immigration detention until you give us
the password to his thing that he's left
with you for safekeeping
to change and then give to him so he can
change it back when he gets out of
immigration detention those are all
things those are like unknown unknowns
right it's a it's a complete black hole
I think by design the government has not
pursued cases where those questions have
come up where it looks like the courts
would find that they were acting
unconstitutionally because they want to
see that ambiguity flourishing because
it they have so much leverage over you
and you're at the border that that
ambiguity really works in your favor I
mean after the Muslim ban one of the
things that immediately emerged when
people said what should you do if was
like nobody knows nobody even knows for
sure so now I do ridiculous things like
I have there's a form I think it's
called the g28
so border guards have discretion as to
whether to allow your counsel to see
when you're in border detention but that
discretion goes away and becomes an
obligation if this form has been signed
and left with your lawyer before you
cross the border but it has to be on
green paper and so I have signed many
copies of this and left it in our
paralegals filing cabinet in EFS and I
always let a lawyer know before I cross
and I always let them know when I'm on
the other side and I hope that they look
check their phone and if they see that
many hours have gone by and they haven't
heard for me to try and call me and if
they don't hear from me again they go
and they get one of these green forms I
bought a ream of green paper to print
these green forms and they bring it down
to the border to see if that's where I
am that's maybe advice for all of our
viewers here I don't know yeah we're
gonna walk around retainer a lot of
green paper yeah and a lot of green
paper rima green paper I have some
leftovers my kid drew on a lot of it but
I still have some leftovers thank you
very much Cory Doctorow Vanessa about
your new novel walk away my pleasure for
reason I'm Katherine Maggie ward
[Music]
you